well for some reason i didn't have
enough of it the first time i don't hate
myself quite enough yet so we are going
back in for a second round part two of
reviewing anti-matt walsh anti-me
tik-tok videos
here we go again this is someone who's
upset about something i said actually
very recently meet matt walsh he's a
douche bag that works for ben shapiro's
company the daily wire and this is what
he tweeted out this morning we live in a
world where nobody can pay attention to
anything for more than five seconds
there's constant stimulation and
distraction everywhere all the time
there's no such thing as adhd your lack
of attention is a cultural environmental
problem not a mental disorder as the
father of a daughter who has adhd i just
want to tell matt walsh
you because
you don't know what it's like you don't
know what it's like when your daughter
is angry at herself because her brain
does not work like her peers brain the
fact that people get mad at her because
of how her brain works and she tries so
hard
so you should probably think about that
before you tweet some [ __ ] here's
what you should think about thank you
for giving me things i should think
about let me give you a couple
suggestions first of all emotional
blackmail is not an argument i made my
point you know about the environmental
factors that contribute to distraction
which at the very like even if you don't
agree that that explains all adhd
it's at least a valid point that any
intelligent person can recognize and
there have been many books written
especially recently about this problem
that we live in a society that breeds
distraction at least if you're
semi-intelligent and irrational person
you you must admit that there's a that
there's something here worth exploring
at least
but you're so much in your feelings
about it that you can't you can't get
past that well how dare you just makes
me feel so bad to even talk about this
well then keep walking bud
okay if the if what i tweeted on my
account makes you upset and makes your
tummy hurt just don't take part in the
conversation let the adults have the
conversation but don't don't try to
swoop in to my own account and tell it
and and just announce well we can't talk
about this no no no it's a relevant
thing going on in society that we are
going to talk about whether you like it
or not second point also is that you
actually have no idea about my own life
experience at all so anytime i have this
conversation about adhd or mental
illness you always have these people who
are like well you have no idea you don't
you've never been through this
how do you know
what i've been through or what i've
experienced or any how do you have any
you don't know you have no clue you're
just assuming that because i've arrived
at different conclusions from you i must
not have had any of the experiences you
have had because you think
in your
little egotistical pee brain
that anyone who has your life
experiences must arrive at the same
conclusions as you because it is
impossible that you could possibly be
wrong that's what you think okay
third
if your daughter is upset
because her brain doesn't work like
other kids
and here's you brought your daughter up
okay you've made it personal i have not
you did that so
you want to talk about your daughter
let's talk about her your daughter's
upset because her brain doesn't work
like other kids your solution
is to agree with her
and tell her that her brain is broken
and needs to be fixed with drugs now
how is that less insulting to your
daughter than my point which is that her
lack of attention is not a disease
and it's not anything wrong with her but
rather a reflection first of all of
childhood and second of an environment
which cultivates distraction so again
you might disagree with my
conclusion and my argument but
i fail to see how it's insulting to your
daughter for me to say no i actually
don't think that there is anything wrong
with her brain
how is that insulting how does that how
is it offensive to tell someone that
there's that i don't think that there's
anything wrong with their brain this
isn't about your daughter
don't hide behind your daughter
this is about you
this is about you feel bad
if somebody calls into question your
decision to give your child those drugs
so at least admit at least admit that
stop hiding behind your kid
all right we'll try this
[Music]
what
i think
i finally read something
so asinine
so
ignorant so
uncivilized
that i actually lost iq points trying to
figure out how this mother
puts his pants on
every morning without asphyxiating
himself
what
well it says on the screen there that
this tweet made him dumber the tweet of
mine made him dumber and i'm scared for
him because he doesn't have much iq to
spare i think i may have just killed
this man what by making him dumber and i
i'm sorry for that you know you may
imagine that you have freedom but it's
mostly an illusion because there are
like two or three companies that control
pretty much all of our online activity
big tech is more powerful than most
countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal data it's time
to put a layer of protection between
your online activity and these tech
juggernauts and that's why i use
expressvpn think about how much of your
life is on the internet sadly every site
you visit video you watch your message
you send gets tracked and data mined but
when you run expressvpn on your device
the software hides your ip address
something big tech can use to personally
identify you so expressvpn makes your
activity harder to trace and sell to
advertisers expressvpn also encrypts 100
of your internet data to keep you safe
from hackers and eavesdroppers on your
network what i like most about
expressvpn is how easy it is to use
download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button and you're
protected expressvpn does all this
without slowing your connection that's
why it's rated the number one vpn
service by techradar the verge and
countless others so stop handing over
your personal data to the big tech
monopoly who minds your activity and
sells your information protect yourself
with the vpn that i trust to keep me
safe online visit expressvpn.com walsh
yt to get three extra months free
we'll go to our final
tick tock here let's see what we got and
this one's a real dizzy you ready
notorious nightmare online poster matt
walsh really gave away the game here
saying he wants to find one person in
the us who really wants to vote that
would find it difficult to do so first
of all you shouldn't have to really want
to vote to be able to vote you should
just be able to do it even if you hate
the process it is your right as an
american but then he goes on to say that
things like voter id
work as an extremely basic iq test for
voters yeah as india impeach we've said
this before we'll say it again
republicans are putting these voter
suppression laws into place because they
want to choose the voters they don't
believe that the voters would choose
them if given the option and now we're
just fully saying the quiet part out
loud once again let's just be aware of
these tactics and do it we can't to stop
it
well notorious notorious nightmare and
poster that i kind of like i might put
that on my resume if i had one
peach this is not the quiet part out
loud for me because it's never been the
quiet part when it comes to my opinions
on things i don't necessarily have a
quiet part i'll just come out and say it
so the fact that i want fewer people to
vote i've never been shy about saying
that i'm 100 clear about it yes i want
fewer people to vote lots of the people
who vote right now i wish that they were
legally prevented from doing so case in
point the video we just watched um
because
there are so many people who are so
overwhelmingly
stupid
and clueless who cares about this stupid
election that their vote is not
really a vote at all like it's because a
vote is supposed to be you're
considering the options and you make a
choice based on what you want
but when you've got just these legions
mobs of drooling morons stupid people
vote
stumbling half drunk into the voting
booth uh every four years or every two
years and like randomly
pushing a button or making a selection
based on a letter next to a name that's
that's not voting that's just like
that's just rolling dice that's it's
even worse than that though because what
happens is these enormously stupid
people can be so easily manipulated
by
you know the government and by
politicians and so then it just becomes
a game of who can manipulate the most
stupid people to do this and on top of
that there are also a lot of people
voting
who don't really have a stake in the
game you know they don't have families
they don't have incomes they don't have
jobs they don't contribute to society at
all and so they're making decisions
about where everybody else's tax money
goes even though they're not
contributing to the pot at all and
they're just not they're not productive
members of society and i think that's
another thing you should be a productive
member of society in order to have a say
in what happens in society to that
extent
this guy didn't actually respond
to what i said
so i'll say it again
i am not aware of a single example
according to our current laws
of a person who really wanted to vote
and yet was unable to do so
because of voter id laws
has that ever happened this guy could
have given me example he couldn't give
one
i don't think you can
and the thing is even if you if you can
if you are able to point to a few people
like that then that only proves my point
even further that these are people so
incredibly dumb that we should they
should be prevented from voting just on
that basis alone
well those are all the people that uh
hate me and there are a few others out
there but look
if you're in the sweet baby gang and you
want to show these people
the truth or if you want to be in sweet
baby gang either way
then make sure that you come back to the
channel and that you hit subscribe hit
the like button hit the notification
bell and do it now